it's the spookiest time of year
but things are a little different this
all hallows eve
to tell us about it it's a rapper no
pumpkin remember how halloween to be
pre-2020 we usually all dress up and
start roaming the streets and make your
dog look like a bumblebee
knocking on doors and demanding the
comedy tv the house of a neighbor we
hate this paper an april would have come
in handy but halloween baby you're six
months late
2019 halloween children and teens they
be rolling all over the town passes by
terrified this group of guys they
decided to dress as the murderous clowns
unleash on the streets disturbing the
peace reaching for pieces of wreath
of the sweets as they scream trick or
treat wearing a sheet and i asked him
you a ghost or the kkk can't be too
careful these days that was last year
but we had a pandemic so i'm sure you're
aware that some things have to change
your course is ashamed to be missing
traditions and awkward parents put in
the position this evening's not one that
kids want to be missing so here are the
differences
[Music]
but this time going as fouchy handing
out vaccines purell in the candy and
frowning at people who doubt me
understand i'm not even leaving my room
i just party i'll zoom it's a shame with
the background i found of an ancient
tomb but remember a lot of things still
be the same we'll decorate the house
hundreds of children will dress up as
native americans with feathers
is it cultural appropriations
[Music]
leave out some candy and we'll overcome
and if you're thinking of going
too soon wait until 2021
you